白い貫通発表になった
肇社長です
いやろんだろついにきたぞ動画のタイトル見ればわかると思うんですけども今日6
決まっいやこれ本当にすごいと思うしで常に本サピーつもここができたらと僕はこの
醤油味ですが思いましたよこれ末レってもいいからね寒い
ニャーニャー池田今日も行くぜ
あっハミド消し止めました
はぁ yeah
キャッチでな金が心配ズブ
月で心配大丈夫かなずっと酸っぱい自己責任壊れてたら俺のせいで大丈夫だと思うん
ですけどもごめんこちらで bs デジ空中する時代ディスプレイさんの部屋にほんと
すごいよ9注入古酒やものが数字に
うんっいやすごいでしょ通帳に行くディスプレイさんがにつきました
汗やですブーツ
いやいや空中にいうかやばいでしょまずじゃんこれ交通わけですてくるかせよ
アダプター
貼って重かった重かっただけた瞬間気づいた点はこれから追われてないかだけ心配も
ブータン
こちらこれが本体のようですねいかにも怪しいねいかに話好きだよ保留の説明書による
と次期頭が内蔵されているみたいでねちょっとよくわかんない
とりあえずが欲しいとってほしいとなってこれかこれがこれがほしいとらしいですよ
とりあえず
住みたいよねみんな皆さんが何を見たいかというと思うことだけだと思うんですよ俺も
見たいからさ
をさせばいいんだよね光った誓ったよ7巻買ったようなんで何が光ってのってことは
効果を着方はそうですね多分
ほしいとをセットして磁石をこれは勝ったとそういうことか
まあねこれ待ってるんじゃねまってまっですあれなんかねうまいこと乗せれば服みたい
です
まあこれマジで薄まってちょっと山のて強くなりましょうフェッチします脚ます光まし
たここ水筒を置きます10センチの高さにチェックを外してください今ぐらいかな
起きましたら配置した場所から上向きの磁力を感じるところがのと重力を感じるところ
で避ければいいのね
感じだ10選手話してゆっくり置いてって led が消えるところで起こっと
ん
つか例じゃないかっ
へっ
タッパなんか
エロいね怒ったら ok なのは勝ったまずはバスを取る高さ
話でい今4つ光ってるよねー
を待って待って待って待って待っていくなって二待って馬ってくまってくまってくまっ
てまってパッチますまたまで待ったって
待って行っちゃダメだピタピタポッ鉄板ってピザヌいてヌいてヌいてる完全に浮いてる
よ
このん
突っ張ってプ板浮いたライターみた第ターバンっと浮いたということはほぼシール外し
ていいんだよねー
うわま時間は待ってるのはマジだ
馬って本当に置いてるよ実も仕掛けもございません
うわぁすげぇな完全に浮いております
まってこれ何でも載せていいのかなどれはパリを見てるよ
ポップうすごいすごいすごいすごいでしょうまじかまじかまじかまじか
ゴミなんかなんかなんか浮かせホルムスもフォン
あ向いちゃうなんても増えちゃうわけうわぁこれマジか本当にすごいお前と思いかなぁ
パーラー左ボタンとかなら全然なるんですけどお茶の抜粋です
えっ
花岡&て下
オサレに見えるよねこれたぶんでフィギュアとか送れば一番いいんですよねいやーこれ
ねー
めちゃくちゃいいよめっちゃいい買い物したと思っていればめっちゃテンション上がっ
てるからすごい本当に拍手
これはすごいなんだろう
ものが上度た空を飛ぶことってすごいをレジュメがあることだと思うんだよねエヴァ見
てテスト感動するアミーゴっとかもすごいかっこいいだけじゃなくてこれを破って完全
自体じゃんダイスケの友達もわぁんじゃいかすぃなぁこれひょっとしたらひっかけさん
福んじゃねこれヒカキンさんくんじゃねを読む僕が親のを浮かせてあげます
親だ右腕の真後ろしたよ
ああああああ
中間1金杯まん
ん